In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for April 20 on which we commemorate the Holy Apostle
Zacchaeus.
A tax collector in Jericho, Zacchaeus, being small of stature, did not hesitate to climb
a sycamore tree in order to see Christ pass by.
The Lord stopped and said to him, Zacchaeus, make haste and come down.
For today I must abide at thy house.
The other people present took Umbridge because the teacher had chosen to go to the house
of a sinner known by all for his repacity.
But Zacchaeus said, Behold, Lord, the half of my goods I give to the poor, and if I have
taken anything from any man by false accusation, I restore him forefold.
And the Lord showing the power of repentance said, This day is salvation come to this house,
for the Son of man has come to seek and to save that which was lost.
After our Lord's ascension, Zacchaeus accompanied Peter on his missionary journeys and became
bishop of Caesarea.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.